Joe Flanagan has been talking about why
he thinks Stargate Atlantis was canceled
and what he actually thinks about
Stargate Universe and he talks a lot of
sense
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV a
movie channel
[Music]
right big front page spread there we are
congratulations on 100 episodes
and
but I don't know that that was it this
is my understanding is that MGM
is going bankrupt and imploded they
really are imploding like you were
calling MGM like literally like maybe a
janitor would pick up the phone right
and you'd hear the vacuum in the back
you're like Joe Flanagan is one of those
people that is just absolutely
fascinating to listen to for me he was
really one of the main reasons why I
loved Stargate Atlantis so much there's
only really Jason Moore and David
Hewlett that could really rival him for
my most favorite characters on that show
and I love hearing him talk about his
relationships with people like Jason
Momoa
um JoJo where's Jason Momoa apparently
used to call him and Jason Momoa is
energy unlimited ability to drink and
have fun and still turn up the next day
and go to work
but on this interview on the shuttlepod
podcast
um with um Connor trynier who actually
played Michael on Stargate Atlantis and
obviously played trippin Stargate um
Star Trek Enterprise and Dominic Keating
who actually wasn't on this podcast but
normally
um Joe was talking about Stargate
Atlantis now in the interview it is very
clear that Joe took the cancellation of
Stargate Atlantis personally
and I just couldn't believe it after I
heard we were canceled and we were told
like we're the last people told for some
reason yeah of course I called up
Charlie Cohen who ran MGM
and I said Charlie what are you doing
dude right what are you doing he goes
well you know this we got to do and I go
dude what if that pilot what if that
show fails you've killed a franchise it
was his show it was a show that he knew
people loved and we did and it was also
show that he knew was making a lot of
money for MGM he did take the
cancellation badly and he expressed
those opinions quite loudly at the time
which made him somewhat unpopular with
certain aspects of the cast and crew
from the show he talks about how
Stargate galantis really only got Klan
songs because of the problems at MGM
basically MGM had this Theory they were
in trouble they had new owners and they
were desperately trying to increase the
value of MGM so they could sell it on
they'd spent 5 billion saving the
company and basically thought it was
only worth maybe three
so they were about to lose a crapload of
money the one idea they had was they
needed a movie and they needed a new
series something to beef up the value of
MGM so that they could get rid of it we
need to get the price of MGM up and then
dump it how are we going to do that a
new movie and a new TV show
and I think we were the only TV show on
the air maybe there's one other one with
Mandy patemkin that was they were doing
but it wasn't doing that well we're
literally were the only TV show and then
they had the bond France yeah yeah for
MGM right and I was like you know all
right and they basically had to make a
choice now Joe Flanagan talks about how
that led to the idea of a new Stargate
show
and the cancellation of his the
cancellation of SGA was basically down
to math they couldn't afford to do both
and there was this theory that a new
show could just ignite everything and
get MGM moving back in the right
direction Joe Flanagan himself actually
says he spoke to Executives he told them
this is a terrible idea what if the show
fails you're killing the franchise
something that we've talked about a lot
on this channel actually we're talking a
lot about this currently with a new
movie plan that actually if MGM and
Amazon go ahead and do a cinematic movie
and it doesn't do very well they could
kill the Revival of the Stargate
franchise before it even gets off the
ground
so Joe Flanagan really knew what he was
talking about at the time the threat
then is the threat that we see now now
SGU wasn't the massive successor they
were hoping it wasn't a failure either
but it wasn't the massive success they
were hoping it never quite found its
footing now there are two camps when it
comes to SGU there's the one camp that
believe SGU only got basically canceled
because of the bankruptcy now other
shows survive the bankruptcy as you
didn't SGU wasn't making the real money
that sg1 and SGA made so that is one
reason why I got canceled but the one
can't believe that is the only reason
the other Camp my Camp believe actually
the SGU just wasn't as good as sg1 and
SGA that they sucked all the joy out of
the show and the big change in tone and
style
really turned off a lot of Stargate fans
and there you go and you have a new show
and that has its own set of Dynamics
and
um I'm pretty sure that most people look
back on that was a bad choice because it
did bury the franchise now I was
actually starting to enjoy SGU towards
the end I found the first season mind
normally boring but the second season
was getting better and Joe talked about
that quite a lot and he made some really
interesting points now he's one of the
first actors that I've actually seen
stand up and admit that Stargate SGU was
basically rebranded Battlestar Galactica
Joe talks about how Stargate was a much
bigger show than Battlestar galactor at
the time but Battlestar galactor was
getting a lot of the critical Acclaim it
was getting the awards and MGM thought
we want a bit of that there are some
people working on the show that like
don't like that like I've been slaving
at these Stargates and we're not we
haven't gotten the critical accolades
again okay we're making money whatever
wouldn't it be nice to be recognized for
the work we're doing and I'm gonna be
honest with you I think Stargate has
always been underappreciated Yeah by
critics it's a way better show than
critics claim it's a great show and
anybody who watches it gets addicted to
it yeah so I don't even need to like
defend the show but my point is I
understood where they were coming from
and Battlestar shot across the street
yeah did it really oh yeah and I'm
friends with all those guys we see what
they're doing over at Battlestar
Galactica we see what Ronald D Moore has
done and we want to copy it now he makes
this amazing Point here that actually
the guys Brad Wright Robert Cooper
Joseph malozi et cetera Etc are doing a
really good show that people love
he says the Stargate Atlantis was making
hundreds of millions of dollars a
question that was making quite that much
money but it was a popular show and it
was making money
so why cancel it and also why would the
makers take something that they're good
at and try to do something else now I've
heard Brad Wright talk about this a
couple of times and he's basically said
what we needed to do something else
we've basically done the same show twice
and we need to evolve we need to do
something a little bit different in a
new series
Joe Flanagan though talks about how look
you are good at doing that you did
something that was really really loved
all the way around the world why would
you do something different
and I actually think Joe's got a point
if you are a really good Carpenter if
you are just amazing with wood and you
decide you know what I want to do
something a bit more heavy I want to do
something more important I want to do
something with iron and I want to build
iron gates and I want to do this sort of
thing it's a very different skill set
you need to have very different basis of
knowledge you need to have a very
different set of tools I'm not sure that
people like Brad Wright Joseph Mosey Etc
were quite ready to do SGU I'm not quite
sure they did have the tools for that
first season
and I think that's why it took them at
least a season to get their foot in
and that's why the show got better in
the second season now normally
in a company that is financially stable
I don't think that would have been a
problem because
MGM would have given Stargate Universe
the time the Stargate franchise was so
popular around the world the fans were
willing to give it the time the problem
though is MGM wasn't on a financially
stable footing it was losing money hand
over fist it was going bankrupt so it
couldn't afford to give SGU the time it
needed and that's why it failed now Joe
does talk about how he could never
really watch the show and he half admits
that was probably a personal thing
because he was just so hurt about what
happened with SGA he took it personally
and he admits that
he says about how he respected the
actors Etc and he really enjoyed what
they were doing but he couldn't watch it
he says it wasn't just a change in tone
to Battlestar Galactica style it was a
change in the way it was filmed it was
changed the way it was edited it was a
change in everything I had nothing
against any of those guys they're all
great actors David blue Robert Carlisle
they're all great actors I want him to
do well right but we were pitched
against each other
and for some reason I was like at these
like conventions and they were like
why I was hearing how angry the people
in the universe were at us for not
supporting universe and I was like well
I don't know that that's my job
the fans will support it or they won't
support yeah I don't get it that's not
my job right and I will say that I did
try to watch it and I couldn't really
watch it because I was like
I can't believe they replaced us for
this and he just couldn't get his head
around it he just couldn't enjoy it
and I think that is what a lot of
Stargate fans that are in my camp
really can understand
that the show was so different it was
taken us a long time to really get our
heads around
and you know it was really only in the
second season that we started to see the
point of the show now Joe does say the
Stargate Atlantis was completely
different to start getting sg1 and on
that point
I thoroughly disagree with him
I think they talk about how SG-1 was
Superman and um SGA was Batman and okay
I I get that on the whole
Stargate Atlantis was a bit darker the
villains were a bit darker you know The
Wraith and the way they murdered was
different to the gold the gold didn't
murder in the same way they weren't
maybe as scary in some ways
and I completely understand what he's
talking about how there was a little
less slapstick even though we all
remember scenes like Rodney getting shot
or you know that's so much you know they
were slapstick there was humor there was
those relationships but I would argue
and I've always argued the SGA and SG-1
tonally were very similar but actually
from a format point of view they were
very similar you know the basic thing
about the team going through the gate
obviously very similar but actually the
relationships I've always thought that
actually sort of John Shepard's
character was sort of like Richard Dean
Anderson's Colonel O'Neill I think that
David hewlett's character Rodney McKay
was kind of similar to Amanda tapping's
character of Samantha Carter and so on
and so on there were similarities
between the characters because they were
set up in a similar way they were always
supposed to be those bromances those
relationships that were like two
brothers squabbling the idea of the
teams coming out of Atlantis was
supposed to be like a family there were
differences there were things that were
done differently but there were also an
awful lot of similarities when SG you
came along they completely threw the
format of starga out of the window and
trying to do something completely
different now the people that love
Stargate Universe that's one of the
reasons why they love it but the people
that really struggles targeting universe
that's the reason why so please go over
to the shuttle pod podcast I'm going to
put a link in the description give them
a subscribe give them a thing because
they're doing really really brilliant
interviews every single week from Star
Trek Stargate and the rest of the Sci-Fi
world
the Robert picardo interview in
particular was absolutely fascinating so
please go and give it a watch and you
know get into the comments and tell me
exactly what you think about it tell me
what you think about Joe Flanagan is his
honesty refreshing or does his mouth get
him in trouble a little bit I'd love to
know exactly what you think
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification you know what to do also
you can follow all these lovely links
that have been scrolling across the
bottom here including the patreon page
where you can see most of our new videos
first
as always please stay safe and I'll see
you next time
foreign foreign
[Music]